et alors non parce que je vous le dis
les règles ont été claires ils veulent
juste voulu poser des questions sur
voilà sur son personnage et c'est fait
au creux des fêtes votre truc et il va
rentrer après il sera là non non non non
non je ne le fais pas tu me le faire
mais ce qu'on fait et c'est lui qui
jubile pas notre jour là il va lui je
veux faire des conneries
après tu as peur de couilles c'est tout
et ben je l'écoutais tirannt ans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais c'était il ya des règles quand on a
invité voilà il ya des règles voit là
[Musique]
l'effet magique s'agissant du
wasquehalien thomas yeux nord et l'ira
s'est depuis trois jours et combinée
[Applaudissements]
et
pablo et c'est michel
oui
[Applaudissements]
on y voit la jeune fille sait pas quand
on voit ce qu'on a dit on va accueillir
un professeur awa la mairie soit pas
l'accueillir dans cet état oui moi
jamais de paris-bercy à mes excuses à
celui qui m'apprennent d'un faux pas
même pas fini sortez les demain d'accord
alors ronnie vous lirez votre poème ou
professeur ou quand il va rentrer voilà
mais je vais le dire à bart et par tous
deux s'aiment pas lui mais vous croyez
vraiment qu'on va faire venir fogar
aller si on paie j'aimerais qu'on
respecte les règles et rené je sais pas
s'il va vouloir vous lisez pas une pas
c'était pas prévu jeudi que vous le
diront merci professeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui bien sûr été coupée c'était le bon
temps où tu vois jamais ce prix ce
polonais je crois vers le plus patent
laurent coletti pas est ce que voulait
la surprise du prophète mahomet défaut
n'est pas égal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cet après midi j'en pleure diputé
mercier michel mado c'est le sosie
officiel de google
[Applaudissements]
les toits sur le manioc de trail
organisé regardez c'est là qu'on vous a
repéré et vous lirez votre toit on est
sûr de rien du tout bas c'est celui-là
c'est d'arrêter le clip pour le voir
michel rien chidiac le hockey ça prend
des années fermes et ça libère les
pédophiles
elle veut bouillard trop con skins pour
être la copie je suis un terrain sud
cognac pour le crocodile y est les temps
changent et [ __ ] c'est pas ben et une
salle que ça part mal cousu dans un
tweet un danger je fais dans sept à
frangy on est venus braquer la vie comme
le casino d'enghien
[Applaudissements]
nîmes la numéro 2 c'est moi qui devais
faire le mec le pauvre taureau mais
c'est comme si j'étais ici la fin des
rallyes terre en aidé kohl à baïji
bichat paris giannoulas le times il veut
qu'on ne peut pas attendre le 2 mai et
du puy-de-dôme jusqu'à bab al mandeb
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que tu viens de toulouse
monsieur je suis surtout besoin comme à
10 cm de toulouse qui l'ont plus piqué a
marché et je te dirai rené bas voilà
mais on pas vous avoir le professeur à
où il va il ajouté 6